[موسيقى]
وفقا للارقام واعتمادا على النصيب المفترض
للموريتانيين
فانه يملك اراضي يا شاسعه ساخره بثروات
طبيعيه من ذهب وفوسفات وحديد ونحاس وشواطئ
من بين الاغنى في العالم بالثروات السمكيه
افتراضا مئات الاف الافرنه الصالحه
للزراعه لكن الواقعه يقول ان ثلثا
موريتانيين يقنعون تحت خط الفقر بنسبه
بطاله هي من بين الاعلى في العالم ثروات
الموريتانيين
في منحي تراخيص الصيد وتعدين وتوزيع
الاراضي وذلك حسب تقريري للخارجيه
الامريكيه ولا تهدا السجلات الداخليه بين
القوه السياسيه
في اداره موارد البلاد
في قصصنا ثروات موريتانيا من يملكها نعرض
قصص معاناه الصيادين في نواذبوا عاصمه
البلاد الاقتصاديه من تضييق سفن التابعه
لشركات اجنبيه كبرى على رزقهم ذلك في غياب
للرقابه الحكوميه وشفافيه في ابرام عقود
صيد الاسماك مع الشركاء الاجانب ثم ننتقل
الى
احدى اثر مناطق الذهب وفيها نرصده واوضاع
المنقبين التقليديين والشكوك في نشاطي
شركه كنديه تتولد تنقيب في هذه المنطقه ثم
ننتقل الى زويرات حيث مناجم الحديد ونطلع
على اتهامات بالفساد طالت مسؤولين في
الشركه الوطنيه للصناعه والمناجم اثنين
والخطط الجاريه للمحاسبه وتحسين اوضاعها
وقد خصنا عثمان محمود وكان وزير الشؤون
الاقتصاديه وترقيه القطاعات الانتاجيه خصم
بتصريح اكد فيه ان حكومته تعطي اولويه
للاستثمار في راس المال البشري لتحويل
موارد البلاد الى ثروه حقيقيه
اما بقيه القصه فنسكملها مع ضيفينا سيدي
احمد ابو المتحدث باسم حزب الانصاف الحاكم
والخبير في استراتيجيه التنميه والعيد
محمد مبارك النائب البرلمانيه المعارض
والمحامي نسالهما عن مكان من الخلل في
اداره ثروه موريتانيا المعدنيه والبحريه
وعما اتخذ من اجراءات حكوميه لمعالجتها
ولمعالجته الفقر المتفش في البلاد واللي
تقييم اولوياته نظام الرئيس محمد وال
الشيخ الغزواني في التنميه في البلاد
نشاهد القصه ونبدا الحوار
موريتانيا البلد الممتاز على مساحه مليون
كيلومتر مربع وعدد سكانها يزيد على اربعه
ملايين
من الموارد الطبيعيه
كشفت التقارير المحليه والدوليه ان
احتياطيه هذا البلد من المعادن في الاعوام
الاخيره يتوزع على نحو بلغ فيه الحديد
مليارته والذهب 25 مليون اونصه والنحاس 28
مليون طن واليورانيوم 50 مليون اونصه 160
مليون طنطا من الفوسفات
وتوفر هذه الثروات عائله ماليه كبيره من
العمله الصعبه فالحديد لوحده يوفر اكثر من
مليار دولار يليه ذهب ب 780 مليون دولار
فيما توفر الاسماك 550 مليون دولار غير ان
هذه القطاعات الثلاثه
رج جدلا واسعا في الاوساط الموريتانيه حول
مصير هذه الثروه وكيفيه ادارتها في وقت
كثر فيه الحديث عن استنزاف مشحف لهذه
الثروات وتفشي الفساد وضبيه الاتفاقيات
الاشغال فيهم
قال لك يعرف
وكل شيء
كانت بحر لا نبغيها حتى وهي العيش بيهم
ولي ومسائل اللي خنتهم وهي نعرف وهي اللي
اعرف هو والديه وجدودي ويا كامل يشتغل
وا علينا ياسر من شيء كان ما كان وكيل
بواخر والسفن تركيا والصينيين والسنغاليين
اثنين قعدنا نحنا قامات
الاقتصاديه لموريتانيا
على طول 720 كم ويسخر بثروه سمكيه هائله
تحتوي على 600 عينه من الاسماء منها ما
يزيد عن 200 عينه قابله للتسويق حسب تقرير
المبادره شفافيه في الصيد البحري لعام
وفي الظرف الذي بلغت فيه الكميات السنويه
اكثر من مليون طن فان شكاوى الصيادين
والمهتمين بهذا القطاع تقر بغياب الرقابه
واستنزاف الثروه وغياب الحوكمه والشفافيه
في ابرام العقود مع الشرك الى ذلك
[موسيقى]
الفتره الاخيره خليك شيء قال له تنافس بين
الرجال الاعمال
مع شركاه والاجانب عدلوا شن قالوا لي
استنزاف الثروه السمكيه الحقيقيه
لو سمحت كم من الصيد القليل وصفحه
الدراسات البيئيه تؤكد ان هناك مستقبل غير
مشرف البحريه وهذا لم يعد خافيا على احد
شركات اجنبيه
[موسيقى]
تجاوزات كشفتها عقود اثارت حفيظه
المتابعين لهذا المجال على غرار العقل
المباراه مع شركه بولي هندنا صينيه على
مدار 25 عاما هذا العقل شابته عده تجاوزات
حسب المنظمه الفرنسيه غير الحكوميه شيبر
المختصه في التصدي للجرائم الاقتصاديه وهو
عقد يمنح شركه صينيه الحق في السيد نقيض
او مراغاه الاستدامه الثروه السمكيه
ويمتعها باعفاءات وامتيازات جبائيه
يصطاد وكل شيء من الاخطبوط للنجم للعينات
الاسماك القشريه للعين كل شيء
وفي غير مكانها
رساله مسربه
يحيى ولد الشيخ محمد فهد الى وزير السيد
النقابه عن اخلالات تتعلق باستنزاف شرس
للثروه من قبل جهات اجنبيه والصيد اثناء
فتره الراحه البيولوجيه الى جانب غياب
الرقابه وطلبت بايقاف جميع انواع الصيد
اثناء التوقف النشاط
وتقوم مجاوره
[موسيقى]
انشوده الخامس
كل الدوله
كان عييت نشوفهم يحوشوا الحوت المحرم
وصوب وشباب محرم الواحد
[موسيقى]
قويه على الاحتيال علي المراوغه
على الاثبات من الرقابه
ثانيا هي مستعده
لدفع الثمن من اجل التغابن من المسؤول عن
رقابه تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق بشكل مطلوب
في الحقيقه الحكومه الموريتانيه
عسكريه مدنيه
[موسيقى]
ولم يصلنا منها حتى تاريخ بث الفيلم اي
وردت
[موسيقى]
غدرنا نواذيبه
احدى اثر مناطق ذهب في موريتانيا هذا
البلد الذي سجل خلال الربع الثالث من عام
2020 انتاج ما يزيد عن خمسه اطنان من
الذهب من قبل المنقبين التقليدي بقيمه
تزيد عن مليار اوقيه جديده
انتاج الشركات الكبرى العامله في هذا
المجال بموريتانيا
[موسيقى]
فيبي عن معدن النفيس لا يبلغون معناهم
الجميع
[موسيقى]
الى خمسه تقريبا وعندنا حد يحصي لنا
وبعدني نسبه
نحن فيه
بعد الهلال والله
انا اوضاعه باين منه بشيء يحفر حظر
[موسيقى]
ويحاولوا معها
يلا الاخير
[موسيقى]
موريتانيا
ذهبي ويمكن الحصول على الذهب في كل مكان
واذا هم يتخبطون
يذهبون في كل الاتجاهات للحصول على الذهب
وتعرفون اغراء الذهب وتعرفون الفنون الذهب
انه معرضون للخطر
لانهم يقاسون عمدان ولكن
ظهر ان له مداخيل كثيره تستفيد منها
الدوله من خلال البنك المركزي الى غير ذلك
القطعه بشكل جيد ومنظمه المنقبين ومنظمه
قطاع التعديل كانت ما كانت بحاجه اصلا
موجوده
تم التواصل مع وزاره البترول والمعادن
والطاقه لمنحها حق الرد وقد اكد لنا
مستشار الوزير انه تم وضع اطار تنظيم
وتشريعي من اجل ضمان الظروف الجديده لقطاع
التنقيب التقليدي عن الذهب مبينا انه تم
اخيرا تعديل اتفاقيه مع شركه كينراستازي
في اطار مسار توفقي اساسه الربح المشترك
واكد التزام الحكومه الموريتانيه
بتعهداتها تجاه المستثمر مع ضمان
الاستغلال المسؤول للثروات الطبيعيه
الوطنيه
حم البحث عن الذهب لم تقتصر على المنقبين
التقليديين فقط بل يشاركهم فيها العملاق
العالمي كيني روستازياست بموريتانيا وهي
شركه كنديه في بورصه تورنت بكندا ونيويورك
بالولايات المتحده
لحقتها تحقيقات قضائيه منذ 2014 من قبل
محققين امريكيين من لجنه الاوراق الماليه
والبورصه بموجب القانون في ذرانه الامريكي
لممارسات الفساد الخارجي حيث وقع اتهامها
بالاستلال على فرعين بافريقيا مقابل سبعه
مليار دولار عام 2010 كما دفعت رشاوه
لمسؤولين موريتانيين في الحكومه السابقه
حجم التعاملات التي تكشفها الشركه وحجم
استثماراتهاليه
اتهامات رفعت منسوب الجدل بشان الاتفاقيات
المباراه
شركه الكنديه كانت كل الاتفاقات اللي تعمل
تعملها
خارج الشفافيه هناك ذهب
عن هناك استغلال مفرط الثروه الموريتانيه
خاصه
اتفاقيه كانت
اكثر يعني اكثر عباره اغتصاب انها تم
تتغير الدوله
محمود يعني اتفاقيات
مستثمر كما يحلو له
شركه
نشاطها
والمواطنون في هذه المنطقه
يتاثروا سلبا بهذا النشاط من ناحيه التلوث
لجنه الاوراق الماليه
950 الف دولار والزامها بتقديم تقرير في
اجل عام واحد للاجراءات المتخذه لتلافي كل
التهامي في الظهر وقد وفقت الشركه على
قبول هذا القرار دون الاحتراف بالتهم
الموجهه اليها او انكارها دفعتنا هذه
الاتهامات الى السعي الى التواصل مع
الشركه لكن دون جدوى
ترتيب نحن مدرين في حد البروفياس من مشاكل
[موسيقى]
قريبه وانا مستعجل انا مستغرب
على سكه تشق الرمال الصحراويه المتحركه
وتصديره زاد عام 2020 على 12 مليون طن ما
جعلها تساهم بعشر بالمئه من ميزانيه
الدوله واحد 10% من الناتج الداخلي الخام
وثلاث واربعين بالمئه من صادرات البلاد
وفقا احصائيه الشركه
ورغم انها تمثل واحد ابرز شرايين الاقتصاد
الموريتاني الا ان تحقيق اللجنه
البرلمانيه الذي احيل الى القضاء عام 2020
كشف عن اخلالات هامه لدى الاداره سابقه في
تسيير اعمال الشركه كانت تؤدي بها الى
الافلاس ملف تحول الى قضيه راي عام ودفع
الحكومه الى اقاله المدير العام السابق
والقيام باصلاحات
شركه سليم
من طرف المساهمين الدوله
يعني الشركه ما يمكن الا بتسيير صناعي
يمكن يعني دخول العوامل الاخرى تكون عند
تغيير سلبي على الشركه
وبصفها اكبر مشغل بعد الدوله تساهم الشركه
الوطنيه للصناعه والمناجم في مشاريعه
تنمويه على طول الخط الرابط
باجراء بحوار وطني مفتوح على كافه
الفاعلين سياسيين والاقتصاديين لبناء عقد
وطني
يضمن تنميه لصالح المواطنين نحن لسنا ضد
الاستجمار الخارجي ولكن ضد همم ان يكون
هذا الاستثمار الخارجي عباره عن استغلال
وقتنا الطبيعيه على حساب الشعب
هذه الجدليه لازالت قائمه عاده لا نميز
بين الثروه المحتمله والثروه الحقيقيه
[موسيقى]
من اولويات الحكومه حاليا راس المال
البشريه في مركزه اهتماماتنا دون راس
المال البشري لا يمكننا تحويل الموارد
المحتمله الى موارد حقيقيه وهذا اساسي
الاولويه لراس المال البشري يجب الاستثمار
عليه حاليا
[موسيقى]
ثروات باطنيه متنوعه تظل في حاجه الى
مسارات حوكمه تتشكل معها احلام شعب يتطلع
لان تتحول ثروات بلاده الى قاطره حقيقيه
لتغيير واقعه وواقع موريتانيا نحو الافضل
في الحاكم والخبير في استراتيجياته
التنميه كما ارحب كذلك بضيف العيد محمد
المبارك النائب البرلماني المعارض
والمحامي اهلا بكما ابدا معك سيد احمد ولد
ابوه انطلاقا مما تضمته همم شهادات في هذه
القصه التي عرضناها شهادات لعاملين في
مجالي همم الثروه البحريه والمعدنيه هناك
فساد هناك سوء اداره وهناك غياب للشفافيه
في موريتانيا لماذا رايك
مساء الخير اخت وسيله تحيه لك وللمشاهدين
الكرام
ولضيفنا الكريم وتمنياتي للاخت فيروزياني
بالشفاء العاجل او لنا في الرد على سؤالكم
حسب ما ورد في التقرير ربما وقع اجتزاء
لمسار تاريخ البلد
يرجع التقرير الى الظروف التي نشات فيها
الدوله الوطنيه في موريتانيا في موريتانيا
خلال جيرانها في الشمال كما في الجنوب لم
تريد من الحقبه الاستعماريه اي بني تحتيه
على الاطلاق
لمؤسسات لابونا طرقيه تحتيه الى مستشفيات
لجيش وكان على الانظمه التي حكمت البلاد
خلال العقود الست الماضيه ان تستثمر بشكل
مضطرب وتراكمي للوصول الى ما وصلنا اليه
اليوم احنا راضون على الوضع الحالي لتنميه
البلد بكل تاكيد لا هل نحن همم مشغلون في
تحسين هذا همم الوضع بكل تاكيد نعم
التقارير التي العناصر التي وردت في
تقريركم همم وضعت الاصبع على على همم
اختلالات جد مهمه لا يمكن لاحد الا اذا
كان مكابرا ان ينكرها هناك فعلا حصلت همم
في همم
سنوات عديده وفي حق اب اقول لعقود متواصله
حصلت عمليات همم سوء تسيير للثروه همم
الوطنيه همم ادت الى ان همم المتوقع
بالنسبه لاقتصاد الموريتاني وبالنسبه
لتنميه البلد لم يكن في الموعد بسبب هذه
الاتفاقيات المشحيفه التي همم كما قال
معالي وزير كما قال معالي وزير الاقتصاد
ربما همم كان هذا نتيجه منطقيه لغياب قدره
راس مال بشري حقيقي مختص ومكون في التفاوض
وبالتالي همم نتيجه اختلالات معينه ومن
ثلاث سنوات تم وقف النزيف اولا ثم بعد ذلك
همم مع وصول الحكم الحالي الى همم السلطه
ثم بعد ذلك وضع اطار جديد لمقاربه لتفسير
ثروات البلد وتحصينها سنعود بكل تاكيد الى
هذه النقطه بالتفصيل الذي يتعلق كل هذه
همم سيد العيد محمد انا مبارك ما تعيشه
همم موريتانيا ليست حالا استثنائيا
بالتاكيد دول عربيه عديده تعاني من الفساد
والمحسوبيه والرشوه وما الى ذلك لكن اليوم
نركز على همم موريتانيا برايك اين الخلل
ومن يتحمل المسؤوليه
شكرا
الاخ الكريم من موريتانيا اقول ان هذه همم
المشكله هي نتيجه لسياسات همم فاسده انظمه
فاسده تتعاقب للاسف الشديد على همم اداره
هذا البلد ولم يكن ابدا من بين اهدافها
ولا طموحاتها ان تزيل يعني الفقر التهميش
والغنن همم يعني الاجابه الواضحه على
السؤال الذي طرحته همم قناه الجزيره من
يملك ثروات موريتانيا هذه الثروه ومقسمه
بين الشركات اجنبيه لا تحترموا اي قانون
وهي مطارده في كل همم انحاء العالم نتيجه
لممارستها السيئه في الفساد والاضرار
بالبيئه والانتهاك يعني همم الانظمه
الاجتماعيه وبين انظمه يعني همم ما في
هويه تتقاسم عن طريق يعني همم
موظفيها وعن طريق همم خبرائها وعن طريق
اليتها هذه الثروه ولذلك الوضع همم ينطق
همم ينطق بحقيقته لا نحتاج ابدا في
موريتانيا اليوم ان نتكلم عن البؤس مناظر
البؤس في كل موريتانيا في العاصمه في
الاحياء في يعني في في في في كل مدينه
بلغت نسبه التنميه بلغت خمسه
بالمئه ضيفنا سيد احمد ابوه يقول نحن
منشغلون بتحسين هذا الوضع هناك اعتراف بان
الوضع سيء لكن هناك عمل على تحقيق
ابدا ابدا اقول لك ان الوضع لم لم يتحسن
ابدا بدليل ان نفس هذا النظام الذي يقول
انه النظام جديد هو يعني
اتحدى ان اجد مسؤولا او وزيرا او مديرا او
مستشارا فيها نظام الحالي لم يكن جزءا
اصيلا ومهما في النظام السابق اذا هم نفس
الاشخاص الممارسات لم تتغير اذا لم يتغير
تتغير يعني هذه الاتفاقيات ولا ما ضامينها
ولا يعني مقتضياتها بما يحقق يعني ثروات
للبلد او استرجاع ثروه البلد اليوم
موريتانيا من بين اثنين وعشر 22 بلد
افريقي همم من بين اثنين وعشره 22 بلد
افريقي هي الاسوا بالنسبه لمستوى الضرائب
والاتاوات التي تحصل عليها من هذه الثروات
اليوم موريتانيا في مجال الصيد البحري
وتكلمت عنه في مدينه لم نستطيع ان نستجب
الا يعني اسوء الانماط الاستثمار في هذا
المجال وهي شركات دقيق السمك بما تمثله من
اهدار للثروه وخطر بيئي ومنافسه للوطنيين
اليوم في موريتانيا في نواكشوط وفي نوادي
وفي كل مدن لا يجد الموريتاني حتى يعني
كيلا كلغ واحده من السمك ياكله بينما يباع
تباع لاسماك في مدريد وفي فرنسا
العام الماضي اكثر من 34 طن من الذهب 12
فاصل ثمانيه مليون طن من خام الحديد
35,000 طن من خام انه نحاس وحجم الصادرات
من الصيد البحري تجاوزت 759 مليون دولار
في المقابل لجات الى صندوق النقد الدولي
الذي وافق قبل ايام بمنحها قرد 86.9 مليون
دولار هل يعقل ان تلجا موريتانيا الى
الغنيه بثرواتها الى صندوق النقد الدولي
وما ادراك ما صندوق النقد الدولي
شكرا سيدي العزيز تصحيح اللجوء الى صندوق
النقد الدولي ليس لغرض تعبئه موارد ماليه
هذا ليس هو والهدف والمعروف بالنسبه
لاختصاص انا صندوق النقد الدولي يعبي
اساسا ويضمن مساعد ااا فنيه وهو بنسبه لجل
البلدان حضوره في همم اقتصاد اي بلد هو
بوليصه ضمان ل بقيه المستثمرين وبقيه
المؤسسات الدوليه الاخرى لهذا نحن بحاجه
في موريتانيا الى صندوق النقد الدولي
تماما كما بقيه البلدان في العالم
وجودهمنا وليس لتعبئه الموارد للموارد
التي تعبر عن طريق موارد محدوده جدا
وتتشكل تسهيلات لميزان مدفوعات ولا يمكن
رسم عليها قطط اقتصاديه هذا اولا ثانيا
همم
المبالغ النقيه التي تفضل حضرتك
اكيد لان هذه المبالغ تعكس همم مخرجات
قطاعات اقتصاديه معينه هذه القطاعات
الاقتصاديه كان يشوبها قدر من همم همم
تجاريه في التخطيط وغياب الرؤيه
الاستشرافيه بالنسبه لتنظيم هذه القطاعات
وحصل همم منذ ثلاث سنوات ما يمكن ان ارضى
به واا على بعض ما ورد في مداخله همم
صديقي همم سيد همم بالنسبه للمراجعات التي
حصلت لتحصين الثروه الثروه الموريتانيه
ناخذ على سبيل المثال قطاعين فقط القطاع
الاول قطاع الصيد في الاتفاق الجديد الذي
وقع همم
نوفمبر 2021 ودخل حي يستنفي بشكل سباق 21
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وصدق عليه قبل الشهور
من طرف البرلمان الاوروبي هذا الاتفاق حين
تمت مراجعته الاتفاق السابق تم تحسين
الشروط التفاضيه بما ضمن ان همم المبلغ
همم على طن السمك تمد زيادته بسبعه عشر
دولار على الطن مرورها من 123 الى 124
طبعا مع تصنيف عتابات مختلفه لاصناف
الاسنان تم ضمان همم توفير التشغيل للطلاق
من مو البحريه على السفن الاوروبيه همم
لضمان دخل وضمان ايضا همم حيازه خبره فنيه
تم ضمان صعود المفتشين والمراقبين
الموريتانيين الى هذه السفن البحري
الاوروبيه لقيام بعمليه التفتشيها وكا رقم
اعطيه لك 70% من مجموعه تدخلات خفض
السواحل العام الماضي اسفرت عن همم تحرير
مخالفات اذن هذا يطرح الاشكال اخر وهو
التحدي الكبير التي تواجهم موريتانيا في
حفظ والصيانه ثرواتها اذا لابد من الموارد
البشريه هائله جدا تكنولوجيا هذه
المخالفات همم لقائي جدا يقول كيف تتجسدت
وكيف تحصل هذه المخالفات قال احد محدثكم
قبل قليل ان الشركات كبيره جدا وعملاقه
والسفن اكيد هيشتركات اما هذه السفن اما
انها تستخدم في الشباك غير مرخصه اما انها
تصطادها غير مرخصه اما انها تعطل مجسات
تحديد الالي للموقع
غير مرخصه محل فقط
عندما يقول صياد بسيط ان الشركات الكبرى
تعتدي على الثروه البحريه بدون وجه حق واا
يتم الصيد الجائر وفي اوقات غير مسموحه
وبدون وجود اي رقابه اصدق من اصدق الصياد
الذي يقتات ويعيش على الصين ويتعرض لهذه
الممارسات ام اصدق التقارير الرسميه
في اتفاقيات سابقه ابرمت باسم الدوله
الموريتاني من طرف اشخاص عهد اليه بتمثيل
الدول الموريتانيه الدوله الاستمراريه لا
يمكن همم الغاء هذه الاتفاقيات مجره القلم
لكن يمكن ما عدد اليه النظام الحكم الحالي
اللي يستلم قبل سنوات هو تحسين الوضع
التفاوضي كلما وصلت اتفاقيه الى حيزه الى
نهايه حدها زمن
يتمراجعتها تحسين وضع التفاؤلطي حصل لهذا
بالنسبه اتفاق الصيد حصل ايضا بالنسبه
للاتفاق المعادن اذ تم كانت موريتانيا لا
تجني من همم عملاق الذهب كان الرسول واذكر
قريش
الا ثلاثه
ثم رفع هذه الى حتى يصل الى 6.5
زياده اذا كان السعر الذهب يصل
1800$ سعر الذهب اليوم قبل دخول الاستجابه
كان 1925 دولار اذا منذ سته شهور نحن في
العتبه الجديده لهذا الاتفاق الاخر الذي
تم ايضا مراجعته وتح هو اتفاقات همم
المرتبطه بالمديونيه الخارجيه لتخفيف عبء
هذا الدين على الموريتانيين وتحس- تخلق
فضاءات ميزانيه لكي تعتقدر الدوله على
تعبئه استثمارات اموال للاستثمارات
العموميه تمت معالجه مشكل ديون نائمه كانت
مستحقه للشقيقه الكويت تعاقبت عليها ثماني
انظمه حكمت البلاد دون ان يكون هنالك همم
ابناء النجاح قبل السنه قبل سنه تمكنت
موريتانيا من اختراق هذا من اختراق همم
تاريخ في هذا الملف هبطت حجه المديونيه من
همم حوالي 80% الى 41.2 الى 41.3% فقط
مشرك همم ضيفنا العيد محمد مبارك بخصوص
هذه التعديلات التي قرات على الاتفاقيات
ان كان اتفاقيه الصيد الاخير الموقعه مع
اليابان او الاتفاقيه الخاصه مع شركه
الكنديه التي تنقب على الذهب والتي ما
تزال تسيل كثير من الانتقادات هل هذه
التعديلات التي طرات على الاتفاقيات ثلاثه
الاخطاء السابقه
اقول لك همم ست وسيله اقول لك شيء ان هذا
الاتفاقيات همم الان يتم يعني همم تغييرها
او يعني اجراء تعديلات عليه مقتدى خاصه
وهي خارجه مطلقا عن رقابه همم السلطه
التشريعيه البرلمان الذي يمثل الشعب هذا
اولا ثانيا ان همم يعني النسبه التي قال
صديقي المحترم هذه النسبه تصل همم
تصاعدت الاسعار في شركه همم يعني الى سته
في فصل الخمسه في المئه يعني مبلغ مضحك
جدا حتى يعني حتى التعديل التقليدي الذي
يمارسهم الان هو يعني همم
يعني يزري اكثر مما نحصل عليه من هذه همم
الشركات لذلك المشكله الكبرى السيد همم
انه يراد لهذه الثروه ان همم يعني تبقى
دوله بين الشركات اجنبيه مطارده في العالم
ولها يعني ممارسات سيئه في مجال البيئه
والمجال الف الماليه ومازال يعني الكوارث
الاجتماعيه وبين حظنا من المتنفذين في
الوزارات واقرباء يعني انظمه الحكم ولذلك
اليوم تمثل يعني همم يعني هذه الشركات
يعني المعدنيه تمثل 1% فقط من نسبه
التشغيل من نسبه التشغيل في موريتانيا
يعني هناك يعني كارثه حقيقيه تتعلق يعني
التوزيع هذه الثروه التي يفترض ان يعني
نتجه فيها تحويل يعني همم للاسف الشديد
حتى الان لانه سؤال من له مصلحه ذلك تقول
ان هذه الاتفاقيات لا تخضع لما يكفي من
الرقابه القضائيه
وهناك تجاوزات عديده همم
ليس ليس فقط انها لا تخضع لاي رقابه يعني
من البرلمان هي اتفاقيات ايضا لا تنشرها
الحكومه بحجه انها تتضمن يعني مبالغه يعني
ماليه سريه وكاننا يعني هناك شيء يجب ان
نخفيه لماذا لا لا نشرها يطلع عليه
المجتمع المدني والشعب الموريتاني وناقشه
ويكون مواقفي منه ويعرف يعني مضمون هذه
الاتفاقيات ذلك انه حتى في هذه المدن في
سويرات وفي زوجت ولايه شيري بالاضافه الى
المخاطر البيئيه الكبرى هذه مدن ينتشر
فيها البؤس التقييم فيها الصحه نسب النجاح
في المدارس قائمه نتيجه لا يوجد هناك
التمويل ولا تاثير لهذه الشركات ولا
نشاطها المعدني سواء التاثيرات الضاره على
الصحه وعلى البيئه وعلى يعني كل نواحي
الحياه في هذه اذا المشكله اليوم هو كيف
نخرج كيف ناخذ نسترد هذه الثروات من بين
الثنائي الخطير ثنائي الفساد الخطير وهو
الشركات الاجنبيه
رغم الفاسده التي
تتمثل في بعض الموظفين للاسف الشديد واهم
موريتانيا ولكن نقول ان الواقع اليوم لا
يستطيع احدا لا يستطيع احد ان يخفي هذا
الواقع البائس رقم هذه الثروات الكبيره
والكبيره جدا
هي ثروات كبيره جدا
هناك مشكله كبيره في الاداره كبيره من ذهب
حديد
وثروه سمكيه هائله نحاس وامور اخرى وحتى
همم غاز
وبترول نقطه في الان مع مشاركه حول قطاع
واحد من قطاعات الثروه المتوقعه لدى
موريتانيا وهو قطاع تصدير النفط والغاز
الكاتب والصحفي والموريتانيه عبد الله علي
يرى ان هذا القطاع يمكن ان يسهم في تامين
فرص عمل للشباب والفئات اله لكنه اعرب عن
مخاوف فهم ان يطال شبح الفساد هذا القطاع
كذلك متابع
ايدات الماليه
يمكن لموريتانيا من خلالها ان تحقق
البرامج التنمويه لهذه الفئات الهشه اضافه
لذلك بدايه تكون وجهه لمرحله لاحقه
للمستثمرين وهو ما يمكن ان تعوي عليه
الحكومه في تحقيق مكاسب لهذا الشعب لكن في
الحقيقه ما يوصف بشبح الفساد والتسير
والحكمه هل هي اشياء تحقيق الافكار
الموريتانيين واذا لم تاخذ الحكومه موقفا
منها خلال المرحله القادمه وربما ربما لن
نرى ذلك لاكتشافات الغازيه لتلك يعني
الدرجه التي كان يعول عليها المجتمع
الموريتاني
وبشان المخاوف التي عبر عنها الصحفي
والكاتب عبد الله علي انقسمت اراؤ صحفيين
اخرين حيل ما تتخذه السلطات الراهنه من
جهود لمكافحه الفساد نتابع ما قاله مدير
موقع مراسلون الموريتاني سيدي محمد ولد
بلعمش الذي يرى ان المرحله الحاليه تشهد
محاربه الفساد عمليه
من خلال ارسال المفتشيه لبعثتها الى مقتل
المؤسسات الوزارات ومن خلال فتح القضاء
لتحقيقات الموضوع ولكن ثم كل هذا من دون
تشير
الان هناك مسؤوليه الساميين في الدوله وقد
قالها المفتش العام للدوله لتمي اتباعه
الى رئاسه الجمهوريه يدفعون اقساط
وما تزداد دفعات تدفع حتى هذه اللحظه
ولد الشيخ سيداتي يرى ان ملف مكافحه
الفساد يتم توظيفه للغايه سياسيه ويطالب
بحصانه الجهات الرقبيه واستقلالها عن
السلطه التنفيذيه
اهم وفصله محاربه الفساد عن السياسه ولا
يمكن ان يتم ذلك الا بحصانه خلال ماموريه
للجهات الرقابيه بمعنى ان يكون المفتش
العام للدوله خضع شخص نزيه تم اختياره من
طرف الرئيس من بيني تصفيه لمجموعه من
الشخصيات وعنده ماموريه وبناء على برنامج
الدوله اليوم في مكتبه تاتيه الاوامر بان
اذهب الى فلان لانه اعظمنا لتفتشه او
بتفرق عن كافلان لانه الان نحن مرتاح هنا
لهنا هذه الهيئات من هذه الاجراءات
الابديه لانه حارب الفساد
عوده الى ضيفينا ابدا معك يا سيد احمد ابو
والحديث عن الاكتشافات المتعلقه بالطاقه
والغاز والبترول لكن هناك خوف حقيقي من ان
يطى لها كذلك الفساد وسوء الاداره الى اي
مدى يمكن ان تسهم هذه الاكتشافات في تغيير
احوال البلاد الاقتصاديه وما الضمنات
المطلوبه لكي تبتعد عن الفساد
خوف مشروع بحكمه العوده الى الماضي وما
طابع ظروفه اختلف ظروف استغلال الثروات
البلاد في العقود الماضيه لكن دعني اقول
لك نقطه تتعلق بالمراجعات التي حصلت ربما
لم يتركنا الوقت في المره الماضيه حقل
مناقشه الاتفاق الجديد لحقل وهو حقل اااا
يختزن بالنسبه للعائدات او المخزونات
تجاريه خمس مرات حقل السلحفاه الذي تشترك
فيه موريتانيا مع السينغال حنين هذه
المناقشه افضت الى مضاعفه حصه الدوله في
هذه الحقل مقارنه بالنسبه التي كانت
تتلقاها الدوله اتفاق 2012 مع مع انيرجي
الذي دخلت عليه على خطه فيما بعد همم
اليوم عندنا حصه 29% من حقل الذي هو خمس
مرات حسب المخزونات التجاريه القابل
للتسويق هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه الثانيه
همم موريتانيا
75% من كان في موريتانيا هم تحت سن ال 35
سنه ماذا يعني هذا يعني ضغط كبير جدا على
التعليم بمختلف مراحله يعني ضغط كبير جدا
على سوق التشغيل يعني ان الاقتصاد وواضع
السياسي الاقتصاديه مرغم على اني يبتكر
حلول جديده لتوفير الاف فرص العمل لالاف
الخريجين سنويا هذا يضيف هذا يدعم راي
القائل ان لا خيار عندنا
ترشيد عقليه همم النفقات العموميه
والموجهه تخصصا للاستثمار لان عائده الغاز
همم النقطه الوحيده التي يمكن ان تعطيني
الموريتانيين هي انها لن يصرف منها
الدولار واحد في نفقات التسير في ميزانيه
التسيير هذه العائدات موجهه حصريا اما همم
الاستثمار العمومي في الاقتصاد الانتاج
لان المشكله الاساسي
موريتانيا اليوم هو النهائي بناتها 60 سنه
على اقتصادهيعي هذه المقاربه كانت كارثه
على البلاد وافضت الى ما افضل اليه من
المشاكل اليوم نحتاج الى تنويع الاقتصاد
تنافسيه الاقتصاد لخ ممكن يخلق الشغل
ولخلق المستوى من الصمود امام الصدمات
الخارجيه حين تحصل وحصلت في القارئ في
الامن القريب المنظور وتحصل حاليا بالنسبه
لهذه الضغوط التضخميه التي يشهد ان العالم
حققنا قبل قبل النقطه الاخيره حققناه معدل
نمو رائع جدا 2022 5.2% هذا جيد
النموين موريتاني فقط يعني عدد قليل
وثروات كبيره جدا يعني هل يعقل ان تكون
نسبه الفقر تتجاوز 30 همم ربما اكبر في
المناطق الريفيه
لو انصفت الدهر لو انصاف الدهر سيدتي لما
كان هناك موريتاني فقير واحد هذه خلالات
واخفاقات على مدى عقود كل لكن ليكون
مصيفين كل الانظمه التي تعاقبت على حكم
هذا البلد خلطت عملا صالحا واخرى سيء في
تفسير الثروه اليوم نحاول اولا وقف النزيف
ما حصل 2019 هو بدايه وقف النزيف ما حصل
بعد ذلك رحله الالف ما تبدا بخطوه واحده
الخطوات التي تلاحقت بعد ذلك هو تحسين
لوضع التفاضيه الموريتانيين المفاوضين هم
انفسهم المستثمرين هم انفسهم ما الذي تغير
تغيرت الايراد السياسيه هذه الاراده
السياسيه هي التي تطمئن اليوم الموريتانيه
على ان بامكاننا النقل بمنحنى الفقر ونوفر
فرص عمل لا يقل للموريتانيين وهذا ما تقوم
به همم الحكومه حاليا منذ ثلاث سنوات على
الاقل في مستوى 30% من موريتانيين اليوم
دخلوا في التامين مؤمنين همم
الغازي هي عائدات موجهه حصريا للاستثمار
العمومي في الاقتصاد
وسيختنيصيه ثانيه
نعم الفكره واضحه اعتذر منك بشده همم سيد
العيد محمد مبارك الاكتشافات الجديده في
مجال الطاقه ما الذي تعنيه بالنسبه
للاقتصاد الموريتاني وما الذي ستغيره من
احوال الناس برايك
لن تعني لي شيئا ولن تعني شيئا كبيرا
للموريتانيين اذا بقيه نفس الاساليب في
التسيير ونفس همم المناهج ونفس الاشخاص
للاسف نحن ابتلى الى الله همم يعني همم
نقبل الشديد لا تولي اي اهميه لهذا الوطن
الجريح رقم الثروات ورقم قله العدد ورقم
يعني همم يعني همم ثروات الكبيره عندما
اقول لك انه في موريتانيا نسب النجاح في
الباكالوريا لا تتعدى همم 10% لا تتعدى
10% ربما هذه السنه وكانه انجاز كبير
تقوله الطبول ويصفق له وصل اتجاه اغنى 10%
يعني
طائرات الدول الاج
منصفين كذلك الرئيس محمد ولد الشيخ
الغزواني تعهد بمحاربه كل الانواع الفساد
بدليل ان الرئيس السابق يحاسب الان ويحاكم
قبل ايام انطلقت محاكمته اليس ذلك دليلا
على رغبه حقيقيه في محاربه الفساد
وسيله هذا يعني نفترض انه فساد يعني قبل
2019 اين الفساد بعد 2019 2020 2020
وندخل في السنه الرابعه هناك فساد لم
تتغير يعني الاتفاقيات لم يتغير الاشخاص
نفس المناهج موجوده لم يتغير حال البلد
قلت لك انه اليوم في بعض الاحيان طائرات
بعض الدول همم الصديقه والشقيقه يعني همم
ينعتها الناس يعني همم
السيارات الاسعاف سيارات سيارات نعم لانه
اقول لك ان ثروات البلد
يبدا الحل اولا بايجاد ان تكون هذه
الاتفاقيات اتفاقيات شفافه تناقش يناقشها
البرلمان وتكون معلنه ويتم نقاشه عن طريق
خبراء وطنيين وطنيين يعني يعني متمكنين من
هذا الجانب وان يكون كل احد ذبت عليه
اشتباه في مجال الاختلاس او يعني التبديد
رواتب البلد انا اقول لك نحن في همم في
2000 تقريبا 2005 اكتشف انها فضيحه
واتسايد يعني يعني في همم اتفاق النفط وفي
سنه 2000 يعني
بعد ذلك نكتشف ايضا انه هناك فضائح تتعلق
همم شركه النحاس في جوجل الان شركه همم
يعني همم يعني همم الحديث يقول عن شركات
السمك شركات يعني همم الصيد التي اصبحت
تملا وشواطئ هذا البلد وتضايق الصيادين
الموريتانيين في كل شبر من ارضهم واصبح
الموريتانيون للاسف الشديد اجانب يعني في
ارضهم لا يستطيعون ان يلجوا الى ثروات
بلديهم ولا يستفيدون منها واصبح التعليم
والصحه يعني والزراعه كلها ضحايا لايادي
هذا الفساد الكبير والمنتشر والاسف الشديد
حتى الان
ربما
التعليم وزير الشؤون الاقتصاديه وترقيه
القطاعات الانتاجيه عثمان ماما دكان قال
ان التركيز يجب ان يكون على العنصر
البشري الاستثمار في الشخص الموريتاني
وهذا لا يكون الا بالتعليم لكن مسار
التعليميه
هو سيء للغايه نسبه النجاح في البكالوريا
العام الماضي لم تتجاوز
10% من الحلول واين يبدا الحل برايك
وجيه جدا ما قالهم علي وزير الاقتصاد كل
معارك التنميه تدور حول راس مال البشريه
اذا كان عندنا راسنا لبشري واذا نجحنا في
تكوين الانسان الموريتاني وتاهيل من حيث
الخبرات الى قياده ااه المسار التنموي
سنكون بذلك قد قدمنا شعبنا وسيكون
الاقتصاد الموريتاني قد ايه ايه ايه ايه
خدمه الى تنميه البلد ومستقبله خلاف ذلك
همم دائما ضرب من الخيال لا اتصور ان
زميلي في الحوار الاستاذ العيد سيدنا
النائب يجهل ما قيمه من جهود جباره في
التعليم وارسال مدرسه الجمهوريه التي همم
يراد لها انت تحل مشكله في التعليم في
موريتانيا وان تخلق اجيال من الموريتانيين
القادرين على تحمل المسؤوليات وعلى الدفع
بالعمليات التنميه الاقتصاديه التعليم هو
همم قطعه السلاح الجوهريه والاساسي في اي
معركه التنميه بالنسبه للتخوفات التي اعبر
عنها زميلي وشاطر في بعضها ولكن لا يتفق
معه في النقاط الاخرى لان هنالك مسار
حقيقي يتطلب مشاركه الجميع ومحاربه الفساد
لا يمكن الا ان تكون عمليه تشاركيا او لا
تكون اصلا نفسي عن التعليق على ما همم ورد
عليه بخصوص المحاكمات وما الى ذلك لان
اتصور ان هذه اعمال تدخل في اطار السلطه
الاقتصاد السلطه القضائيه
المتحدث باسم حسب الانسان
والمحامي اشكركم متابعين على هذه
المشاهدين على هذه المتابعه طبعا قدمت هذه
الحلقه نيابه عن زميلتي فيروزي يعني التي
اتمنى لها الشفاء العاجل الى البرنامج
[موسيقى]